make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing to play catch-up
we're covering the second part of
immortal Hulk the one where you fight
the Avengers and I want to be dangerous
here I want to have this discussion
about like well breaker Hulk versus
immortal Hulk because it's kind of this
debate that's like raging across the
internet right now we're like everybody
in the in the comic book fandom is just
kind of like who would win here um now
there are a couple things to bear in
mind here there are a couple things
going on with this little particular bit
of a story and to kind of pick up from
the immortal Hulk which you can find the
whole first volume down in the
description the idea here is of course
Bruce Banner has been back for a little
while really he's been he's been back
since like the events of Avengers No
Surrender and and one of the things that
kind of came out of that was the idea
that the Incredible Hulk and why this is
called the immortal Hulk is that the
Incredible Hulk seems to be inherently
immortal which is to say Bruce Banner
kind of sat down and said okay The
Incredible Hulk is quote-unquote died
multiple times and always they've always
managed to find a way to come back
meaning the Incredible Hulk is basically
indestructible and cannot truly be
killed now in reality this kind of seems
like a love youing basically saying hey
look guys so we're probably gonna kill
the Hulk more than a few times whether
during my run or somebody else's run
after mine so don't worry
Neen credible oaks always gonna come
back and for those people who have been
reading comics long enough I mean hell
we could have told you that at the
moment as it stands right now The
Incredible Hulk is essentially kind of
come out of his battle with Sasquatch
with Walter lankowski right now
sasquatch is not a hugely important
thing this is really kind of a Ewing
seemingly you know seem in a kind of
rapid review a few plot threads there
were sort of dangling during a towards
really towards the end of like The
Incredible Hulk
going in like Secret Wars 2015 where he
was basically draining off the energy of
people who were gamma-irradiated it
really kind of seems to be like Al
Ewing's sort of clearing the field right
like pruning the tree and just kind of
making the Incredible Hulk title his own
but regardless of the circumstance the
Incredible Hulk is more amped up now
than he was before and that's really the
first part of our discussion when it
comes to you the Incredible Hulk really
immortal Hulk vs. world breaker whole
world breaker Hulk was rage incarnate
right like that's basically what he was
he was pure unadulterated distilled rage
angry as The Incredible Hulk had ever
been but all roads lead to Rome
achieving a certain level of strength
can be done in a multitude of various
ways and the immortal Hulk running
around and draining off the gamma
radiation of various people is a way to
amp up his power and kind of move him up
to a higher level of strength now al
viewing up to this point is not really
explicitly stated the Incredible Hulk is
on par like the immortal Hulk is on par
with will breaker Hulk there's really
kind of us to sort of determine by what
we see but one of the things that's
going on here is that following the
events of the incredible hooks by
with with Sasquatch and the fact that
that link house key had essentially been
like possessed more or less and it
killed a handful of doctors what this is
done is it's led to a guy named general
40 and essentially just kind of
blackmailing Alpha Flight now a little
bit of catch-up here for those of you
guys who were unfamiliar with this
because in reality the only way you
would really know is if you were reading
the Captain Marvel line of stories which
after the events of Civil War two she's
really really been unpopular when it
came to Carol Danvers because she was
free-floating for so long what Marvel
did is they kind of took the old iron
fist and Power Man approach to like
Alpha Flight and Carol Danvers and what
I mean by that is is kind of running
back a little bit further iron fist and
and Luke Cage were like really really
popular when they first came out then
they lost popularity within the span of
like a year and so what Marvel did is
they kind of brought them together under
Mary Jo Duffy and said you get Power Man
and Iron Fist Heroes for Hire and that
was kind of a way to boost their
popularity by throwing them in as a team
and ultimately the title was canceled as
a results of Jim's shooters and it's
royal decrees as the editor-in-chief of
Marvel but it's kind of what's going on
here right like Carol Danvers had been
free-floating for a long time for like
25 years she was free-floating but in
that interim period between 2012 and the
time of civil war two came out you had
Marvel take Carol Danvers and throw her
on to Alpha Flight and then have her
lead lead sword the Cynthia world
observation and response department and
so what that meant was that was awful
flight being a Canadian superhero team
that nobody ever really cared about
throwing them on and having them operate
a sword basically meant that Carol
Danvers oversaw all operations that
dealt with sword in his charter
monitoring space and then Alpha Flight
was basically her strike force team and
so with that being the case right now
but alpha fly basically being the strike
force team and Link Kowski having killed
the doctors is good old-fashioned
blackmail it's general forty and working
through Thunderbolt Ross who always
wants to capture the Hulk and basically
saying if Alpha Flight does not go
through and capture the Hulk then
lankowski will be held responsible for
the lives he took even though he wasn't
really cognizant of what he was doing so
it's kind of forcing the hand of Alpha
Flight which in turn forces the hand of
Carol Danvers now the discussion of that
now flight really has here is they sit
down and they say we cannot capture the
Incredible Hulk by ourselves and so
Carol Danvers kind of responds by saying
I'll assemble my my own little Avengers
team and so what she does is she gathers
Ironman with the Hulkbuster Ghost Rider
Black Panther Thor Captain America of
course and then she-hulk
and so what they all end up doing is
trying to stand their chance against
amour Hulk now then this attack like he
immediately takes the Incredible Hulk
I'm sorry gives the word like
a concussion with one punch now Thor
kind of speaks up and says like he's
more powerful than he has been but this
does not mean that Thor's saying he's
more powerful than he's ever been
that's a big distinction there if we if
you were to say he's more powerful than
he's ever been then that would supersede
World Recor Hall could we basically be
al Ewing saying immortal Hulk is
stronger than world record all it means
is that in the moment emeral Hulk is
incredibly strong and incredibly durable
so again it's kind of left to us to
decide what it is that we're gonna pull
off but one of the things to keep in
mind here is that when Thor starts
talking to Captain America he basically
says like what earth seems to have
reproduced here with it with the
returning Incredible Hulk is that he's
essentially kind of a god it's something
close to a god not really a God with
something close to a god now the
incredible hulks always been on that
level right like me Incredible Hulk once
his strength reaches a certain point
he's always been sort of God to you in
terms of what he could do now it doesn't
mean he's on par with Galactus right
like The Incredible Hulk decides he
wants to fight Galactus galoshes would
just phase them out of existence and
that would be the end of the Incredible
Hulk and that fight would be 5 seconds
long but when you're talking about like
strength you're talking about like Thor
either relating it to himself who is a
definitive God or somebody more powerful
than he is now of course The Incredible
Hulk being able to give Thor a
concussion with one punch that's no
small feat not only that you've got the
Hulkbuster armor which Hulk just tears
apart in the blink of an eye now again
that's not really a major feat here
because we've seen The Incredible Hulk
do that before that's not really a major
feat here instead the closest indication
that immortal Hulk is on power or
possibly exceeds well breaker Hulk comes
in the satellites that Tony Stark uses
to depower him now these are not the
same satellites that were used during
well breaker hawk they basically
satellites composed of hard light
they're basically like bombard the
Incredible Hulk with UV light and
essentially hit him with the power of
the Sun and and that's kind of what it
comes down to of course the Incredible
Hulk losses and the immediate vicinity
is totally destroyed but what we're
seeing here is a Ewing kind of giving us
tidbits of what immortal Hulk is truly
capable of but not really giving us a
fleshed out you know real discussion
here on the feats of immortal Hulk and
so because of that there's not really a
lot of information to go on here that
kind of goes into that to the next
little bit when you basically have him
taken and given to general for T and
then in turn experimented on by general
for T and scientists they literally
dismember the Incredible Hulk right like
they use adamantium knives and various
weapons and things like that and they
basically like dissect him chop him into
pieces but
immortal Hulk is still alive and so
again we're seeing like higher levels of
durability we're seeing like a higher
level of healing factor when it ends up
turning out that the only reason why the
immortal Hulk wanted to be captured was
for the sole purpose of being able to
see what his own feats were right
because what this is this is all Ewing
kind of saying even when the immortal
Hulk was resurrected and came back to
life even he himself realized he was
able to do things he wasn't able to do
before how far does this go and so in
this instance we're you know really like
this doctor kind of realizes hey you
just want to see what you're capable of
immortal Hulk shatters a glass and all
his pieces start reconstituting
themselves and then in turn like
reconstitute themselves around this
doctor who just kind of gets like
smashed meshed inside immortal Hulk
which is a pretty gruesome way to die
and then in turn like immortal Hulk just
kind of breaks his way out but what
we're seeing here is again higher levels
of durability we're seeing like an
enhanced healing factor because we've
never seen The Incredible Hulk
dismembered before and then in turn kind
of restored we'd never really seen that
take place so it's a whole new kettle of
beans with regards to the powers that he
possesses here but probably the the most
damning little piece of evidence here
when it comes to the immortal Hulk is
when it kind of like stumbles across
when when Bruce Banner in his normal
human form kind of makes his way through
and steals like from an old man's
clothing line or whatever it is some
probably some crazy guy in Texas and of
course he you know ends up shooting
Bruce Banner and then like the
incredible kind of there's like hey look
I'm gonna punch you a little bit but
like I'm not gonna kill you and then
just kind of storms off that's it but
the introduction of crusher creel really
kind of seems to be like the damning
piece of evidence in terms of immortal
Hulk vs war breaker Hulk and why world
breaker Hulk comes out on top and the
reason why I say this is remember
crusher creel is the absorbing man and
he's kind of given this sort of banner
gene package as is explained in the
sense that like it's injected in him and
basically he kind of gets like the
ability to absorb gamma radiation that's
really what this kind of goes into now
for those of you guys who were
unfamiliar with crusher creel he's
really one of the more underrated but
supremely capable characters in Marvel
Comics crusher creel is a guy who can
basically absorb the properties of any
kind of material and then turn his body
into that material right like crusher
creel can touch steel and then become
steel he can touch brick and become
brick he can touch iron to become iron
and so he's wildly capable and so if you
were to fight fight him in like a
construction area Oh he'd be almost
indestructible and so with crusher creel
showing up and fighting the Incredible
Hulk with this kind of enhancement
package what isn't going on here is
something that we've never really seen
before the absorbing man literally
starts fighting immortal Hulk and then
turn starts absorbing bits of his gamma
radiation as they fight but the fact
that the absorbing man the fact that
crusher creel can go toe-to-toe with the
immortal Hulk is an indication immortal
Hulk is not on par with Roberto Hulk
because if he was this fight would have
ended like that but again we never saw
immortal Hulk face off against absorbing
man so we don't really know how the two
translate to each other not only that
there's of you a few variables here the
fact of the absorbing man can absorb
bits of gamma radiation now changes
everything because as this goes through
it's one of the things we're absorbing
man gets stronger as The Incredible Hulk
gets weaker so he's literally siphon off
the incredible folks power now it's kind
of a cool thing here because there's
something going on behind the scenes
that was not readily apparent before it
when the Incredible Hulk essentially
fought sasquatch
because Sasquatch was possessed whatever
had possessed him heaven man had been
passed to immortal Hulk when immortal
Hulk had absorbed the gamma radiation of
sasquatch and so what this meant was
that this kind of dark evil persona
which had been manifesting as Brian
Banner what's it passed to the
Incredible Hulk is now passing itself
directly to crusher creel we didn't
really know what it was initially it was
oh my god the father' Bruce banners back
in you know whatever Peter David and it
was very easy to dismiss which
admittedly I was guilty of doing the
thought you made is that what we end up
finding out here is that this persona is
not Brian banner it was masquerading as
Brian banner instead this is a being
referred to as the one below all and
this requires some explanation as most
of you have been dying for and it seemed
like nobody really did explain it
because I watch a lot of the videos on
this and they were just kind of like
it's a thing that's happening moving on
I guess that's why I'm comments
explained so in Marvel Comics Satan is
not an absolute construct and the reason
why I say this is that in Marvel Comics
the the concept of health is
multifaceted right so like having our
discussion on help from Asgardian mythos
for exam we talked about her multiple
times that when Jack when Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby first created the concept of
hella within Marv what kind of adapted
him and modified traditional Norwegian
mythos that hell was just the afterlife
for everyone who died those who died an
honorable battle went to Valhalla those
who didn't went to hell and that was
basically yet when mistress death was
was created then that started
introducing and really kind of spawned
out all these different iterations of
health and then different wider sort of
bringing in the concept of like how
these how this kind of relates to
humanity and so over the years and
Marvel Comics not so much by editorial
decree but because of just
worked out that way through various
stories you've had the creation of what
are called hell lords and these are
basically beings who kind of rule over
hell right so for the most part with the
exception of hella who's kind of out
there by herself hell is a singular
place but there's this like this massive
realm this kind of massive dimension
that is overseen in certain little areas
by different beings and different people
are sent there for various purposes
right so like you've got Hell which
belongs like a part of Hell which
belongs to Mephisto and then you've got
like satanic black heart these different
concepts that exists out there in
relation to like what hell really is how
it actually functions and so on and so
forth hell is an actual place that
exists and there are different concepts
your different consoles with it now in
terms of what it is it all Ewing's doing
because of the fact that the Incredible
Hulk
ends up going to help that Al Ewing may
change that in its entirety but that's
one of the things that kind of goes on
here is pressure tree oh and this one
below all popping up here kind of
changes the landscape because there's
only ever been a one above all saying
the one below all seams injuries what is
definitively the absolute Satan in
Marvel Comics but if that's true then it
would follow sue with like traditional
Western Christian mythology in the sense
that the one above all would be like the
Marvel Comics stand-in for like the God
of Abraham basically and the one below
all would be the actual Satan like
Lucifer Morningstar tried-and-true that
kind of thing that ties into like
Western traditional like Baptist
Christianity that kind of thing so again
we don't really know exactly how this is
gonna play out it's still a concept
being fleshed out by al Ewing but
because of the fact that that crusher
creel is now possessed by this one below
all being it literally manifests itself
by like splitting crusher creel in half
and just like talking through a skull
it's like the creepiest thing ever but
in the middle of this whole fight where
the the Hulk u.s. group that originally
kidnapped the Incredible Hulk or at
least does that Hulk was handed over to
after the whole thing world while he was
being experimented on they're still
trying to track him down alpha flight
still trying to track down the
Incredible Hulk so on and so forth when
this happens while this whole event is
going on in waddle Hulk sees crusher
creel at running off into the distance
and realizes what's happening there what
had essentially taken place when the
gamma bomb originally went off and
transformed Bruce Banner into the
Incredible Hulk what it did is it
cracked open a door to another dimension
but that door never fully opened with
crusher creel being the absorbing man
what he can do is effectively absorb all
this gamma radiation in New Mexico and
then open the door all the way and is
actually a really cool concept because
what this does is it moves
crusher creel away from being a guy who
can just absorb physical elements and in
turn like a guy who can absorb like
abstract concepts which would really
move him into like God to your status to
be honest but the incredible hoax is
down it says like this door this green
door is now open and literally alpha
flight the immortal Hulk they're all
yanked in and to the other side of this
green door which is essentially the
realm of the one below all and so that's
cool because what's basically gone on
here is the Incredible Hulk has been
sent to hell but let me know what you
guys think about this and I want to know
your thoughts how do you guys think the
immortal Hulk stands against world
breaker Hulk because what Rick or Hulk
did not have the ability to absorb gamma
radiation but immortal Hulk does and so
I'm kind of curious to see what you all
think about this but without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later purse
[Music]
[Music]